CBS News senior political analyst John
Dickerson covered former President Bill
Clinton's impeachment trial back in 1999
and he joins us now with what viewers
can expect from the trial of President
Trump John good morning morning Tony
so Senator McConnell has laid out his
ground rules for what he hopes to be a
speedy trial he's apparently coordinated
these with the White House what are the
risks and rewards of his strategy well
if we think about this politically just
in terms of political risks and rewards
because this is a political process in
part we have to think about it that way
let's start with the rewards for
Republicans they are a big fans of this
president and so if you as a Republican
our scene is defending this president
and keeping the Democrats from trying to
hurt your president then you get
political rewards with your Republican
base the downside of course is that
Republicans look like enablers look like
they rush the process through and that
they protected a president who done
something wrong and didn't even really
want to investigate whether he'd done
something wrong and that puts them on
the hook for future presidential
behavior if they're seen as enablers and
the president goes on to do something
that people really do find objectionable
then opponents of those Republicans will
be able to say you know you enabled this
behavior there are a handful of
Republicans here who are who could be
critical in deciding whether there are
witnesses in this case whether there is
more evidence talk about the position
there and they're generally considered
to be moderates who have tough free
election fights coming up in the fall
they're in a difficult position for this
reason you had a new CNN poll out that
said 51% of the country thinks the
president should be removed 69 percent
of the country wants to see witnesses
fifty eight percent of the country
thinks the president did something wrong
so the the country essentially thinks
there should be a process here that's a
little more extended well that's not the
Republican position at the moment these
moderates have to weigh between the the
president's position which is that he
did nothing wrong at all and where they
likely are which is that he may have
done something wrong but it's not
impeachable they have to ride those two
horses between the president's position
in their position all the way to
election day okay so if they say he did
he did put the pressure but it's not
impeachable to do they have
constitutional grounds to stand on they
admit okay yeah a pressure but that's
not enough to remove him from office
well the constitutional ground will be
something to fight over so both sides
are gonna try and figure out what the
actual constitutional turf is we're
going to
a lot about that the Constitution is a
little mushy on the question of
impeachment but when you read the
debates of that hot summer in
Philadelphia they were jittery about
power and so this question of abuse of
power is right in the center of what the
framers were worried about and the
reason they were worried about powers
they thought it was they called it a
cancer and they felt like if you gave
somebody power the inclination of the
human spirit would be to abuse it that
was just natural and so there had to be
these checks on it and that's what
impeachment is about leaving aside
whether the president is guilty of it or
not that's what they were the most
concerned about and that's really where
this conversation should take place and
they would have known back in 1776 that
high crimes and misdemeanors did not
refer to actual legal questions but
rather to judgment calls I mean
impeachments have happened over insanity
drunkenness pure mismanagement
throughout the history I was gonna say
to the president's lawyers now they were
gonna defend him on these grounds we've
got Ken Starr and Alan Dershowitz among
others
Jay Sekulow what do you make of the team
well the team is yeah when we watch this
impeachment we should think about all
the different audiences out there and
there's the audiences of the senators in
the room but then there's also the
television audience the base audience of
the Republican Party the base audience
the Democratic Party all these different
audiences
some of those lawyers are picked for the
at-home viewing audience a Republican
Party they are conditioned to speaking
to that audience they've been doing it
on television for years and that's part
of what what that mean for the country
the outcome is known John we know what's
gonna happen in the end here you'll be
acquitted so what does it mean what it
means is this is an opportunity to look
at whether that means basically because
this is an election year this is a look
at this president and the way he
operates it's a central question of our
government whether the president can use
his power for personal purposes that's
what's at issue here now it hasn't been
proved but that's the central question
goes right to the heart of the
government does this person who's been
given power on behalf of the people use
it wisely and that matters particularly
here not just with respect to whether
he's impeach we think that he's going to
be acquitted but whether he gets
reelected and whether people would like
four more years of the pay viewer that
will be laid out in the course of this
Senate trial all right John thank you
very much I feel like should point out
the impeachment I was referring to were
of judges there has not been a president
impeached for drunkenness as of yet no
no no quick clarification I'm right John
thank you very much
you